sprechen sie englisch sprechen sie
englisch wie viele sprachen sprechen sie
wie viele sprachen sprechen sie meine
muttersprache ist deutsch meine
muttersprache ist deutsch
es tut mir leid ich spreche kein deutsch
ich kenne nur ein paar wörter auf
spanisch ich kenne nur ein paar wörter
auf spanisch gibt es hier jemanden der
englisch spricht hitze jemand der
englisch spricht
ich spreche jeden tag englisch
ich spreche jeden tag englisch warum
lohnt es sich viele sprachen zu lernen
warum lohnt es sich viele sprachen zu
lernen
ich habe in einer sprachschule deutsch
gelernt
gelernt ich verstehe viel aber ich finde
es schwierig selber zu sprechen
ich verstehe viel aber ich finde es
schwierig selber zu sprechen sie
languages ist super zum sprachen lernen
wie sie language es ist super zum
sprachenlernen stimmt stimmt